cadeau des métis du canada pour que le
chef de l'église catholique marche avec
eux dans le long chemin de la guérison
et de la réconciliation
après des mois de préparation
le moment tant attendu est enfin arrivé
le pape françois pu entendre de la
bouche même des survivants toute la
douleur à ceux ci au pensionnat une
rencontre fructueuse où le pape a fait
preuve de compassion d'ouverture mais
qui n'est que le début alors que des
excuses se font toujours attendre
l'église a jadis voulu les assimiler les
dépossédés de leur identité aujourd'hui
les métiers sont venus au vatican en
partant leurs couleurs et en jouant des
airs traditionnels
une victoire un baume après une journée
forte en émotions et en souvenirs
douloureux
cette survivante venue de l'alberta et
des particulièrement ému après sa
rencontre avec le pape
pendant longtemps les 65000 inuits du
canada se sont sentis impuissants face à
l'église colonialisme le tête-à-tête de
leurs représentants à fait remis de
quelque peu rééquilibrer le rapport de
force le rencontre aussi des qualifiée
de positive par les délégués mais elle
sera vraiment vu comme une victoire
comme ça confirmera sa venue au canada
une demande de longue date
chuck
michaud
cette première étape ce qui est
essentiel selon sept survivants de coup
droit marteau grec souhaite que les
inuits d'iris et puis ce même jour par
donner à l'église ses erreurs mais elle
a d'abord besoin d'entendre l'acte de
contrition
morceaux format un fellow fois mardi
mathieu cela dit ce ne sont pas tous les
autochtones qui sont prêts à pardonner à
se réconcilier avec l'église
oui parce que geneviève quand on suit
les délégations autochtone ici on
prévoit que consensus justement chez
tous les autochtones du canada avec
cette idée de récolte de réconciliation
incluant l'église avec cette idée de
main tendue vers le vatican alors qu'on
s'attend à d'éventuelles excuses
aujourd'hui les délégués qui lui est ont
dû apporter une nuance assez importante
en rappelant que dans leurs communautés
se sont pas tous les membres se sont pas
tous les leaders qui sont d'accord avec
cette idée d'inclure l'église dans la
réconciliation pour plusieurs
autochtones au canada le souvenir des
penseurs est encore tout simplement trop
douloureux pour même accepté l'idée d'
excuses du pape certains ne veulent tout
simplement pas qui est de contacter même
entre les groupes autochtones et le
souverain pontife
soyons clairs les délégations qui sont
ici à rome et sont absolument déterminés
à obtenir réparation ajustements
accomplir ce que le leadership
autochtone demande depuis des années de
véritables excuses sincères de la part
du pape mais c'est important tu n'y es
quand même que les autochtones ne sont
pas un groupe homogène que pas un
consensus se sont pas 100 % des
autochtones au canada qui sont d'accord
avec la démarche qui est encore aussi
présentement à rome merci beaucoup
mathieu boyer au port
on va